if you don't mind asking i'm really
curious what
like how what made you start all this um
you know i'm just fascinated with how
people
tend to willingly self-destruct and just
ruin their own lives and and
i've been fascinated with that since i
realized people were doing it in my life
and even i do it to some extent yeah and
it's um
and the more i do it i've done well over
2000 of these interviews the more i do
it the more i kind of get a better grip
on what's causing it
and why people do it and why they can't
stop doing it yeah you see patterns
yeah well there's certain things that
certain
parts of their childhood usually they're
repeated over and over and over and that
that's the stem of it all and then
it just repeats generation after
generation yeah it's crazy
but that's super cool yeah and i think
we all go through it
oh yeah everyone to some extent i mean
these are maybe the more extreme stories
on my channel mm-hmm but everybody is
struggling with this kind of stuff yeah
yeah to some extent so that's why that's
why i think it's it's been so popular is
because
you can relate to these stories even if
yeah even if you think you're not a drug
addict which i'm not or you're not a
prostitute or whatever but that
self-destruction
is something that we all have yeah yeah
exactly it can be there's so many
different
ways it plays out whether it's you know
drugs or alcohol or gambling or shopping
or laziness or
or just your personalities it pushes
people away or anything
yeah so exactly so that's that's what
got me doing it that's so cool yeah
all right scarlett scott uh where you
from where'd you grow up um
i was born in oregon but i kind of moved
all over the country as a kid i moved to
north carolina
virginia montana but i mostly grew up in
la los angeles and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
when you were young um yeah so
i was born my parents got divorced when
i was in kindergarten
but um up until then i don't really
remember much so up until i was six
i don't remember much and then um
once my parents got divorced my dad
moved me and my three siblings to
california because we were all born in
oregon
and he got remarried because he was
having an affair with my mom
and that's what caused her divorce um
and then the woman he was having an
affair with eventually became
our stepmom me and my siblings and
um yeah how would you describe your
childhood
um confusing very confusing a lot of
i was told a lot of different things
from different people from
my mom my dad step parents friends
relatives
so and they were all very opposite so it
was hard to just figure out what was
you know what was true and what who was
just feeding me the right information
yeah you finished high school i didn't i
dropped out my junior year
um because i overdosed on xanax in
school in history class
and then i just i never went back so
drugs kind of came into your life at
what point
they came into my point i started
drinking alcohol when i was 12
um and right as i right as i started i
just
it it took off and it led to other
things i was offered
pills first before i did it smoked weed
anything else
at school and that was when i was 13.
i started taking adderall and xanax
and that really heavily affected my
memory
and i started noticing that and i think
my family and friends sort of started
noticing that and it started affecting
my grades i was a really good student i
had straight a's
and then seventh grade everything just
kind of plummeted
yeah so you
went on your own at what age um i
i can't really say i was on my own but i
in a
in a way i've been on my own my whole
life i've always had
some sort of parent figure but they
haven't always
even if they've been in the house and
they haven't always been there you know
um or they've left a lot of step parents
a lot of my dad's girlfriends
um will come in and leave yeah so it
just caught
caused a lot of um i think
i didn't have stability ever and how old
are you i'm 18. you're 18. yeah
so you've been in you've been in l.a for
how long
i've been in la on and off for
probably about 10 years 10 years
so some of your family members live here
yeah most of my family lives down here
my mom lives in oregon
my siblings all live down here my dad
lives down here but i don't
i don't speak to my family there you go
no and your drug use is kind of
continued
yeah it got it it wasn't very it was
when i started people attributed it to a
lot of other things
my parents or my dad thought i had a lot
of
mental health issues so when i was on
drugs
and i would act out i would be diagnosed
as bipolar
schizophrenic all these things which i
wasn't but i didn't
admit that i was using all these drugs
and all these all this alcohol
and then it didn't really come to light
until i started overdosing
and my first overdose was in eighth
grade and then
since then i've been in rehab um on and
off in jail
yeah and what's your drug what is xanax
but i've dabbled in everything i was on
crystal for a while
pretty heavy what kind of stuff did you
go through
as a kid so okay so my the reason my
parents got divorced
my dad had an affair and my mom ended
up finding out that it wasn't his first
affair
and it was he had also had affairs not
only with
random women but with her friends as
well
so i found that out at a really young
age and i didn't really understand i
mean i was six when it all happened
and i was probably about seven or eight
when i started
getting all the you know rumors or
information
about what was happening and it was all
again mixed from
my mom and my dad this happened this
didn't happen so again that was
confusing
um but basically the woman
my dad the main woman my dad had an
affair with he ended up marrying and
leaving my mom
and then we all moved down to california
me and my siblings my mom stayed back in
oregon so i never lived with my mom
um except for up to six so when i was
six i
i didn't live with her um so my mom
stayed in oregon we als
we all moved on to california and my
stepmom
um ended up we ended up seeing just
patterns and behavior that again i
didn't realize
what they were because i was so young
but she had bipolar disorder
and she was an alcoholic had really bad
depression
um the first thing i noticed that was
like really or i think the
the most the first very traumatic thing
in my mind
when i think of my childhood is um when
i was
woken up in the middle of the night by
like just
so much noise and i was really scared
and i
opened my bedroom door which i shared
with my little brother and
a bunch of firemen were running up the
stairs and one came to the door and just
told me go back to sleep and i was like
i'm not going to go back to sleep
there's a bunch of firemen in my house
but i peered out the door and my i saw
my stepmom
being wheeled out in a stretcher and
there was blood everywhere
and i found out from my sister that
night that she tried to kill herself
with scissors when she was drunk
um so that even though i don't remember
like the whole night and i didn't see it
happen it was still really traumatic
and i didn't know she was um i didn't
know she had any problems so i didn't
see anything until then
and that was kind of scary to see at a
young age um
and then i don't think she really hit it
after that so once we moved
from my dad moved us from california to
north carolina across the country when i
was
going into seventh grade i think i was
13. and
that that was like a huge thing that i
don't think
we realized at the time how big that was
like moving across the country that
young
and not really having a plan knowing
nobody over there
that's where my stepmom was from so she
wanted to move back there um
but we we ended up moving there and i
got into school there
um at my at my school in california i
was it was fine i had friends you know i
was a normal kid and everything and then
once i got there it was just
i don't know what happened but i i guess
just the new kid but
nobody talked to me i was just a loner
and i just had that label from day one
for whatever reason and i wasn't i
didn't not not
not talk to people you know i was
friendly i was outgoing but nobody
talked to me no but for whatever reason
i don't know why
um so for two years seventh and eighth
grade i had
zero friends i ate lunch in the bathroom
it was really hard and
sorry um during that time
a lot of stuff was going on at my house
too
just a lot of my stepmom was um
she would just come into
um my room or thank you or my sister's
room my older sister
and a lot of times i would hear
i'll be like and i would hear her go
into my older sister's room and yell at
her
for no reason and then i would just hear
my sister crying
and when i would talk to her about it
she didn't
say much and she would just have panic
attacks
and so i think from i think from a young
age we all just kind of had
a lot thrown on us and so
yeah she would have she would have panic
attacks i would go into her room
try to calm her down and it would be
over nothing my she would go into her
room and yell at her
calling her disgusting because my sister
has ocd um
calling your names come into my room
yell at me
call me fat call me hideous don't know
why i'm 13 don't know what i'm doing i
don't have any friends at school and now
you know my p and my dad's not doing
anything he's sitting right there
watching it
um i don't know just
it was hard um and then outside of that
i my sister was in place
she was in theater um
and me and my little brother would go
and watch her
at high school because we were in the
middle school and it was connected
so um one night we were watching the
play
and an older boy
from the high school started talking to
me um
and he got my number and i was really
excited i was
nobody talked to me no guys talked to me
um and here's this 18 year old he was
really handsome
i remember and i was really excited to
get his number
and thinking why in the hell is he
talking to me nobody talks to me he must
i don't
does he not realize does he not know
like who i am i'm a freaking loner
um but anyways he
texted me it was my first time sneaking
out again i thought super exciting oh my
gosh i'm 13 i'm seeking out to see a boy
so exciting um i climbed out we were in
a
our our home there was really big we had
many acres
it was i had to climb out go onto logs
get out and everything
i ended up meeting him in his car we
drove
he um said he wanted to go to an
abandoned church
that him and his friends went to to
drink at and at that point i had been
i've been drinking for a while for about
a year um
but i it wasn't it wasn't
bad i was drinking but i wasn't you know
i was functioning i was fine
um he ended up
we ended up going to the church parking
outside and he gave me a drink the drink
was roofied but i didn't
no it was just thought it was alcohol
so we went to the church and i started
feeling
wrong right away just off
and unsafe i remember feeling very just
like uncomfortable just like i want to
be home i want to be
just in my covers i don't want to be
here i don't know where i am
um very weird feeling i never felt that
just
uncomfortable weirdness um
and then he he raped me
at the church i remember parts of it
um and i remember him
um sorry dropping me
back at my house and um
me going up to my bathroom and just
undressing and looking at myself and
just seeing bruises and
i had no one to talk to i didn't tell
anyone um
i couldn't even tell my parents or my
siblings
and i had no friends um to tell so
i started using pills um
when i was offered them and they became
easier to get
i became i began knowing more people who
had them and it was all i just
it just took everything away when i when
i first took xanax
i can't even tell you it was that's why
it's my drug of choice
it's the memory for me it takes my
memory away everything
and even though it's not good because it
takes my even when i'm off of it
you know it affects my memory my
long-term memory um
when i'm on it it's the best feeling
because i don't have to think about
the past the present the future
anything
and how are you supporting yourself now
um
right now it's pretty difficult um
i i have ways to make money it's just
i don't have much money but i'd rather
not get into it
yeah so you've been in pro
in trouble with the law as well yes um i
caught a case when i was 17
for carjacking and robbery again very
complicated story i didn't it sounds
like i just robbed someone jacked their
car it's not how it went down that's
not that type of person um but i did
take all the charges um and
i was um in juvie for four months
almost four months and i was supposed to
be on four years probation
and i right as i got out i
i was sober for those four months in
jail my head was clear i felt great
i really did and i i promise i was
talking to my mom i wasn't talking to
the rest of my family but i was talking
to my mom and
it was good we made a plan i was gonna
finish school get my ged again i tried
to get my ged before but
went on the run didn't finish it um we
were planning everything getting back
into rehab
and then got out of jail um
first thing i did smoke some weed i said
that's all i'm gonna do i'm just gonna
that's all i'm gonna do because i have a
drug test in what a month i can
just get out there's one time that's all
the next day smoke some weed
maybe next day a little bit more and
then
call my xanax plug and now i'm looking
for crystal it just
it was a whole thing and i couldn't it
just
for the life of me i don't know why no
matter how bad i wanted it when i was
sober
i wanted it so bad when i was in jail i
promised myself i was never
ever going to use it again ever never
not even going to drink
and the first thing i did when i got out
was do it not even thinking i just
i just did it didn't even think so that
that really messed me up
um but anyways that was very off topic
um i was supposed to be on four years
probation but since i did do that and i
didn't stop
um again it was on me i was i knew i was
going to film my drug test
when they screened me so i decided to go
on the run
because if i
turn myself in i get four years so i'm
that's not what i'm trying to do yeah so
you're you're on the run right now
i am how long has this been going on
um i've only been on their own for about
a week yeah
and if they find you you're four years
four years
four years
so do you have any friends um
that is also a loaded question i can't
say i've i have
friends that i don't have any friends
right now
i can say um
i don't have anyone yeah i don't have
anyone i can call that would
that is in the only person i can think
of that i can call that would
do something for me is my mom but she
doesn't live near me
she lives in another state so are you
even talking with her no i'm not you're
not
no
so do what do you worry about what's
your biggest concern
my biggest concern is um
i guess
just living figuring out
if i want to live if i how much longer
it goes on how much sorry that sounds
really heavy but just
it's a lot and it's just too much
sometimes so i think my biggest worry is
just
when is it all just gonna stop and just
like when will i get a breath you know
what emotion do you deal with the most
um
i think regret
and sadness probably depression
depression definitely yeah how bad has
that gotten very bad
since i was young definitely since since
my parents split
yeah they were like suicidal or anything
like that yep yep
a couple attempts yeah
and do you make the connection with
anything in your childhood in the
situation you're in
yeah i didn't really go into a lot there
was a lot a lot of
a lot of trauma a lot of abuse um
with step parents with boys at a young
age men at a young age
that just i think that's why that's why
when i a lot of things happened prior to
me taking
that first drink when i was 12 that
when i when i felt that first effect
like when i felt
just not exact like not connected to
reality when i felt a disconnect and i
could i didn't have to think about what
was going on
it was like the best feeling and i was
only 12. like that's really sad
so all the pain disappeared yeah it just
all went away and then i just
it and more pain added on worse pain
and it never stopped and then i just
added more drugs more alcohol
everything what kind of abuse um there
was
sexual abuse some physical abuse but it
was mostly
emotional abuse yeah in the house yeah
so it's pretty rough childhood you had
yeah it was
yeah and living on the street how do you
how do you feel this has
changed you it was i didn't always live
on the street i'm
not from a bad home i'm
i'm not my parents had
good money are you in a tent now i am
yeah
um part of it is or it is my choice i
chose to use drugs i chose to do all
these things
um are your siblings in a similar
situation they're not
no they they're all in contact
um they live they talk yeah
they live in a home what do you wish was
different about your childhood or your
life that
i wish would make a big difference today
i i don't
i don't know if i would change it
because
i i don't know what i would do without
it like it's
it's i feel like i've matured a lot just
i'm only 18 and i feel like i've just
seen
and been through a lot even though it's
most of it's not good stuff
and it's not stuff that anybody any
child or any teenager should
go through but a lot of things has has
like molded me you know
and then maybe be able to live around
here and do not be messed with
it seems like once you go through that
kind of stuff it becomes your reality
yeah for sure it's not like you can
imagine a better life or a life without
that
yeah exactly and it becomes your world
and you almost try to recreate it
with other abusive relationships and
stuff for sure yeah
do you see yourself doing that i do i
have very destructive
patterns like the guys that you hook up
with oh yeah not
not good usually not good for me um
yeah i just don't you know i mean what i
what i'm learning
it seems is a lot of these people that
have been through things like you
you have it's like the brain gets
rewired
yeah and what's good gets pushed away
you have no use for it and what's bad
becomes attractive
yeah so you end up making these bad
choices over and over again yeah i've
always wondered why i've always
even as a kid i feel like i've always
gravitated towards that bad crowd
or yeah if you're offered and if i was
to come along and offer you a good
situation
a way out i don't know if i would you
wouldn't want it yeah and i don't know
why i honestly don't know why
i've seen it so many times now it's it's
become a pattern you either flake
and just disappear or you get angry at
me
because i represent good and that that's
just a nuisance and it's like
it makes it it's hard to accept makes
you feel guilty i've been through
rehab i'm enthusiastic i've tried it's
very difficult
i can't i can never stay that's what
i can't i don't i can't imagine my
future
a year from now like i really don't know
what to expect and it's just really you
know it's just
kind of taking a toll yeah it's almost
like you need to repair it yourself
yeah yeah if you can imagine that if
yeah you'll love yourself and yeah and
almost
rebuild your self-worth and your
your subconscious almost to uh
to feel like you deserve better things i
don't even know if that's possible but
that's that's what
yeah that's the only hope i see yeah
what's the most painful thing that
you're escaping from you think
um memories
of the like sexual abuse or whatever
yeah yeah lots of
horrible yeah what's the most important
lesson you've learned
um it sounds cliche but not to judge
people
like i yeah i just try to be friendly to
everyone i meet
no matter what they're going through and
i'm just i've met some really kind
people in
some really bad situations and i
wouldn't have if i
you know weren't in the situation myself
so i'm grateful for that too that i've
met
some of these people yeah do you feel
betrayed by your family or
in some ways yeah some by some people
more than others
um i don't feel angry at my family
not angry at all just i think
my parent figures because when i say
parent figures i didn't just have my mom
and dad
i have stepmom stepdad you know my dad's
girlfriends
many girlfriends so i had a lot of
different parent figures
come in and out of my life and i just me
as i know i'm not
grown yet but as i'm older and i can you
know
i feel more i have that more motherly
you know those motherly tendencies i
can't imagine
putting a kid through that like what me
and my siblings went through i just
don't understand
how a parent can like sit even if
certain ones didn't inflict it they
watched it happen or they let it happen
and i just that's really messed up and i
don't know how i could how someone could
i'm not ready to forgive him yet yeah
well you can break the cycle then
i am i hope do you still have hope for
your future
i can't say um i wish i could say yeah
um but a lot of times no i just
i just want it to end
all right scarlett well i wish you the
best of luck i hope you figure out a way
out of here this is a dead end i mean
look around and look at the people that
are
you're all older than you yeah yeah it's
a
it's a hell of a way to go with your
life it is
thank you thank you
you